picture this mysterious character
introductions mindboggling devil fruit
powers and unexpected powerups that
leave you completely dumbstruck whether
it's cranking up the intensity of
spacular battles or triggering character
development these flexes Drive the
storyline ensuring viewers remain on the
edge of their seats as characters
undergo transformative Journeys so today
vinu brings to you the top 20 one piece
flexes of all time as a tribute to the
OG of shown in anime which has kept us
hooked and hungry for over two decades
at number 20 let's kick off with an
unassuming yet impactful incident
Luffy's one punch knockout of Bellamy
the hyena in the G
Arc
a now this moment links directly to an
early encounter between redhead Shanks
and the bandits an incident Witness by a
young Monkey D Luffy now as a rising
star in the pirate World himself Luffy
faces a similar situation where he and
his first mate Rono aaro are humiliated
by Bellamy and his crew after being
labeled cowards and dreamers for
refusing to fight back the spectacle
initially disappoints the story data
unfolds into a satisfying rematch with
Bellamy and the stakes are raised when
Luffy's wanted poster boasting a bounty
of a 100 million berries comes into The
pirates's Possession initially
dismissing it as a hoax Bellamy soon
learns the hard way that Luffy is not
one to be trifled with the rubber boy
teaches the bully an unforgettable
lesson for hurting his friends what
makes this moment memorable is the
absence of Hy's infusion or involvement
in any grand scheme or event it's just
Luffy standing up for his friends and
living out one of his coolest moments in
the early days
[Music]
next up Sanji makes a timely entrance to
rescue his crew mates from a grim and
watery
[Applause]
demise known for his reliable behind the
scenes Miracles this time s assumes the
identity of Mr Prince to save his
friends from the clutches of shii bukai
and Barack Works head honcho sir
crocodile in the alabaster Ark the
challenges are overwhelming a fast
flooding room a sea Stone cage confining
Luffy and the rest enormous banana wani
Gators lurking dangerously close and an
impending Civil War yet Sanji pulls off
a dazzling entrance and swiftly and
skillfully incapacitates one of the
monster Gators with his trademark kick
Mr Prince not only saves the day but
also frees his mates just in time to
confront the enemy and thwart the
Rebellion this is just one of many
instances where Sanji makes an
invaluable contribution and consistently
comes to the aid of his crew the straw
hat Cooks unwavering and invaluable
support makes him an indispensable asset
to the crew rightfully securing his
place as the second wing of the future
pirate
king our pick for the 18th position is
none other than kaido's Majestic
entrance in wano as he unleashes his
devastating blast breath and obliterates
an entire Mountain
[Music]
top as the ninja pirate mink Samurai
Alliance assembles in wano to confront
the yonko they're in for a jaw-dropping
moment as the Colossal pirate emerges in
his mythical dragon form dwarfing the
landscape drunk and belligerent kaido
demands to face off with Luffy and FAL
Galore who responsible for disrupting
his artificial devil fruit trade the
moment kaido unleashes his devastating
dragon fire at Odin Castle erasing all
trace of it and annihilating the
Mountaintop it stood on feels like a
cruel second blow to the already AG
grieved kuki family despite their
beloved status the straw Hat's pale in
comparison to this Terror in this epic
first encounter setting the stage for a
highly anticipated Monumental
Clash
from a mythical dragon's blazing Inferno
the spotlight shifts to Notorious Crime
Boss crocodile his ball challenge to
Luffy giving him just 3 minutes to show
him what he's got before he gets taken
out is in the 17th
[Music]
spot crocodile's absolute confidence in
his his Sans sand abilities and
shichibukai Status leads him to
underestimate the budding pirate a
sentiment that's Justified at first as
one of Luffy's first big adversaries
crocodile with his formidable loia type
Powers poses a substantial threat
particularly in the absence of Hy
notably he stands at a first and only
villain to completely defeat Luffy not
once but twice in the present scenario
The Narrative has taken a captivating
turn with crocodile forging an alliance
with dracule mihawk and Captain buggy
both former members of the shii bukai
they've started the cross gear with
buggy assuming the role of its head and
earning the title of yonko in this
backdrop that early glimpse into
crocodile's enigmatic and menacing
nature adds intricate layers to his
Persona and as the Intrigue deepens it
leaves us eager to unravel the mysteries
of crocodile buggy and mihawk's
Collective
agender coming in at number 16 is a man
capable of unleashing kicks at the speed
of light
Admiral kizaru earns his spot on this
list as he effortlessly executes one of
the fastest takedowns in one piece
history defeating not one but four
supernovas basil Hawkins X Drake urou
and scratchman appu mind you rookies
they might be but these four Pirates
have bounties exceeding 100 million now
at a glance k 's distinctive appearance
with his vibrant yellow suit and stylish
glasses does set him apart his
introduction to is flashy as he enters
The Fray riding a cannonball his
nonchalant laid-back personality creates
a deceptive facade that catches everyone
off guard including the four Pirates Who
find themselves incapacitated by his
light based powers in no time the
Admiral's dazzling display not only
shows off his individual prowess but
also emphasizes the overwhelming might
of the world government deemed to be the
greatest military
power
[Music]
oh onto the 15th spot as the competition
for the title of pirate king grows
fiercer and our hero confronts
increasingly tougher adversaries let's
revisit an early incident that being
Luffy flexing a conscious burst of
conqueror heart against hod Jones and
his 100,000 strong fishmen
Army in his Showdown with the fishermen
pirate Skipper who aspires to claim the
prestigious title for himself Luffy
displays the progress he's made during
the 2-year time skip his haki tsunami
instantly harves the enemy forces
leaving everyone including his own crew
matate stunned all those years ago the
incredible display of power was a clear
giveaway that Luffy was headed for
greatness now that he's been crowned
yonko after his exploits in wano he's
closer than ever to that Apex Luffy's
latest achievement places him alongside
fellow Emperor buggy Blackbeard and
Shanks his mentor and most formidable of
the three as the most recent episodes
teas shank's decision to go after the
one piece we're left wondering how the
story will unfold and what it means for
Luffy with so much going on in the
current narrative this early hany
explosion still stands out as a killer
example of Luffy's
potential
[Music]
for like Captain like crew the straw
hats deservingly take the 14th spot with
their bald yet honorable declaration of
war against the world government
undertaken solely for the sake of their
nakama Niko
[Music]
Robin
unlike conventional pyate Crews the
straw hats Excel not just in strength
but also in the tight camaraderie
amongst their members their uniqueness
lies in their family-like bond and the
inherent nobility of their personalities
and intentions making each member widely
adored it requires immense courage and
unity for the entire crew not just Luffy
to defy the world's most powerful
Organization for a recently joined
member that too on their own turf
collective decision is truly commendable
who can forget that standout moment when
Luffy displaying uncommon resolve
commands Usopp who disgu as so King to
shoot down the world government flag at
any's Lobby the Ripple of fear this bald
act sends amongst the Marine Spectators
underscores the crews full hearty yet
remarkable
bravery
in 13th Place we have Shanks who makes
up for his long absences from the story
line with a few moments of Epic
awesomeness look in here the scene off
Falls with the citizens of wano
celebrating the end of kaido's Reign of
Terror with festive fervor but unknown
to them adid the Jubilation a Sinister
Force emerges newly appointed Marine
Admiral ryoku gu arrives on the isolated
island to kill Luffy but just as he
starts wreaking havoc on the red
scabbards and their new Shogun Munos who
was still recovering from their battle
injuries an unexpected savior intervenes
the redhair yonko holds the rampaging
Admiral in his tracks with his conqueror
Hy un Leash from a considerable distance
this extraordinary demonstration of
power serves as yet another reminder of
the significance of Hy it echoes kaido's
assertion that hary alone determines the
strongest much like Goldie Roger who won
the title of pirate king solely through
his Mastery of Hy as thrilling as his
display of strength is shank's sudden
appearance off the coast of Wana raises
intriguing questions the mystery
surrounding this Flex at a layer of
anticipation leaving fans eager for
more at number 12 is the famous first
encounter between mihawk and Zoro where
the veteran completely humiliates the
rookie who dares to rest his title of
the world's strongest
Swordsman
[Music]
former shiuk guy mihawk has been a
master of flexus since his introduction
very early on in the one piece Saga in
his first appearance he arrived solo on
a tiny boat and proceeds to sink Don C's
entire Armada even cleaving his gallion
in half with a single stroke of his
Infamous black sword on meeting his hero
and future Mentor Zoro challenges him to
a jewel to the death only to have mihawk
respond with taunts brandishing a
miniature blade against zoro's three
sword style hawy easily overcomes the
green horn sword fighter it becomes
apparent later that this wasn't a
deliberate slight on mihawk's part but
rather a reflection of the vast power
disparity between the two men rendering
Zoro incapable of contending with the
veteran of full strength nonetheless
considerable progress has been made
since his encounter with Zoro maturing
in Leaps and Bounds maybe in a rematch
he could now stop mihawk's giant sword
with a regular old knife who knows times
have changed and so has
Zoro
[Music]
for taking the next SP is the
extraordinary story of kuki Odin's
triumph over death as a rightful heir to
the country of wano Odin faces the
cunning duer of Orochi and
kaido
captured and condemned to a gruesome
execution by boiling Odin accompanied by
his steadfast retainers the red
scabbards confronts a daunting Fate The
Crafty villains agreed to spare them on
the condition that they survive an hour
in boiling oil now this episode is one
of the most emotionally charged scenes
in the entire Saga vividly illustrating
Odin's extraordinary resilience he not
only survives the boiling ordeal but
also succeeds in preserving the lives of
his retainers however he's ultimately
shot dead by kaido in a striking blend
of Victory and despair Odin faces his
demise with his trademarked smile and
flamboyant posture revered as a hero by
his countrymen as the impending doom
that looms over wano becomes an
undeniable reality after enduring 5
years of humiliation as The Idiot Lord
Odin's Death Becomes a shining example
of great sacrifice and supreme strength
of
will
[Music]
oh it's time to unveil the top 10 and
traal Gore Hypes It Up by slicing the
island of punk hazard in half along with
the treacherous vice admiral Virgo an
officer and spy of the donkeyote
[Music]
family
L actions carry grave implications they
take us back to his childhood with his
mentor donot rosinante while attempting
to save his young Ward's life rosinante
dies at the hands of Virgo and his own
brother Don kote doflamingo leaving L
with a lasting trauma with Virgo's death
on Punk Hazard Laur not only avenges
rosinante but also destroys the sad
laboratory on the island a facility
especially set up to create kaido's
artificial smile fruits this puts
doflamingo kaido's broker in a
precarious position law rightfully
describes his actions as breaking the
gear as he successfully spoils doy's
plans leaving him no room for a comeback
but beyond the Strategic implications
the visual spectacle of the island being
sliced apart is truly flexor it
demonstrates Law's growth in the two
years since the marineford war and
disproves doflamingo's faith and Virgo
Superior Armament hary which supposedly
could block any attack including LW
spatial cutting this sets the stage for
Law's confrontations with doflamingo and
kaido Paving the way for the events in
dress Rossa and subsequently
[Music]
wano taking the ninth spot is the moment
that introduced us to one of the most
explosive Power Systems in the series
conqueror
hary one piece Creator Ichiro Oda makes
a brilliant move by having silver Ry the
right hand of the pirate king do the
honors dark King Ra's entrance at the
auction house in sodi with a grand
display of conqueror's Hy is nothing
short of spectacular this rare and
Powerful form of Hy can be wielded by
only a select few ry's seasoned and
legendary status adds to the Grandeur of
its premere emphasizing that only a
figure of his caliber could do justice
to such a momentous scene the complexity
of the moment goes beyond the immediate
Display of Power as it holds layers of
re ations that require careful
analysis another display of conqueror
hary takes the eighth position as shank
steps on board the Moby dig to rendevu
with
Whitebeard now the mere mention of
Whitebeard in in Shanks is enough to
instill fear even in the highest ranks
of the world government and when these
two formidable figures meet the world
observes in hushed awe a Shanks advances
his conqueror's hary causes whitebeards
less powerful subordinates to succumb
one by one and the mighty ship itself
creaks and groans under the immense
pressure of his haki this is undeniably
Shanks at his most menacing a far cry
from the Carefree smiling pirate of
Luffy's childhood memories this Shanks
embodies a formidable presence worthy of
a yonko and this early power display
sets the president of The Skys splitting
conqueror Hy clashes to come reflecting
on This Magnificent scene and the
previously mentioned exhibition against
rugu shank's character gains more depth
and an absolute for boing Aura
simultaneously it heightens the Intrigue
surrounding this Legendary Pirate
building anticipation from what lies
[Music]
ahead
irreverence is a flex as Luffy
nonchalantly brushes off big mom and
kaido which is our pick for number
[Music]
[Applause]
seven when it comes to the Emperors of
the sea their reputations carry immense
weight but in Luffy's case there's
absolutely no force in the world that
would instill fear in him this attitude
is on Full display as he faces the two
colossal Pirates at top the scull doome
in Oni gashima true to his character
Luffy completely disregards the yonko's
questions and strides past them to get
to the fallen scabbards in response to
this insult an enraged kaido attempts to
strike him only to be swiftly knocked
down by Luffy as the chosen one who will
take the title of the next pirate king
Luffy demonstrates in this moment that
confronting two yonkos doesn't
intimidate him in the least although he
typically avoids putting on airs this
incident propels him from being a mere
rookie to embodying the attitude and
stature of a genuine yonko now prepared
to contend in the big leagues Luffy
boldly declares to his adversaries his
ambition to become the pirate king at
this moment in Luffy's character
evolution is not just gripping it fills
every one piece fan with
pride next up at number six is zoro's
legendary nothing happened moment a
testament to his unmatched bravery in
the face of
[Music]
adversity defying odds that would break
most zor's deep loyalty to his captain
Luffy shines through with his Monumental
sacrifice with Luffy down and out after
defeating gecko Moria and ORS the crew
find themselves in Dire Straits with a
formidable Bartholomew Kuma standing in
their way despite G Grievous wounds Zoro
steps up to save his Captain's life and
even after absorbing all the damage
Luffy sustained in his clash with Moria
and his zombie army the stoic swordsman
Stands Tall defying what seemed like
certain death a man a few words his only
response to the incident is the iconic
line nothing happened this incident is
the greatest demonstration of zoro's
indomitable Spirit showcasing not only
his physical strength but also the depth
of his character his willingness to
sacrifice his life and dreams for his
captain speaks volumes it sets the
foundation for the evolving bond between
Zoro and Luffy captivating fans through
subsequent events including the intense
battles in
wano whitebeard's Unforgettable last
stand against the Marines in the
Paramount War comes in at number
five
[Music]
for can a pirate Ascend to the status of
a hero the one piece Saga intricately
blurs the lines between good and evil
providing a compelling platform to
contemplate this enduring question a
prime example of this is the Battle of
marineford where Whitebeard takes the
fight to the Marines in a bid to save
his adopted son P gasty Ace from
execution the veteran pirate acclaimed
as the strongest man in the world
single-handedly inflicts massive Danger
on the keepers of Justice reducing their
headquarters to ruins never have we
witnessed a battle of this magnitude
this colossal Clash unveils whitebeard's
superhuman might derived from consuming
the Tremor Tremor fruit which grants him
the ability to unleash Quakes that could
easily destroy the world however it's
only when the Marines strike at his
emotional call by killing Ace that they
awaken and the sleeping giant within him
despite his fearsome power whitebeard's
revealed to be a man of kindness and
steadfast principles extending his
protective mantle over entire nations
and that's why even as he falls the
Valiant pirate dies a
hero one
piece the theme of justice and Injustice
continues and brings us to our fourth
pick where Luffy fueled by a sense of
moral outrage delivers a single
resounding punch to a Celestial
[Music]
Dragon at the auction house in sodi
Luffy Witnesses the gross discrimination
fish men are subjected to by humans when
his mermaid friend Camy is on the brink
of being auctioned off as a slave Luffy
refuses to submit to oppress Ive
Authority fully aware of the
repercussions of challenging the world
Nobles our Brash hero teaches the
abusive St charos a lesson he'll never
forget for the rest of his life beyond
the pleasure of seeing Justice served
hot and fast and a disgusting villain
put swiftly in their place this scene
solidifies Luffy suitability to become
the next pirate king a title that goes
beyond mere measures of power and wealth
rather it symbolizes adherence to
principles and the rebellious Spirit
Champion by the first pirate king Roger
in embracing this responsibility as he
moves towards his dreams l he proves
himself capable in every aspect he
embodies the essence of what it truly
means to be the greatest pirate to rule
the Seas Now All That Remains is to
patiently wait for his triumphant Ascent
to the
[Music]
summit the intensity escalates as we get
to the top three and first off is Zoro
as he takes on a fearsome new Avatar
during his clash with King the
wildfire
not fighting for their captains both
contenders put their lives on the line
in a battle that surpasses the ordinary
after clashing with kaido and coming out
of it close to death Zoro miraculously
resurrects to engage in another
phenomenon Showdown with King the
choreography is Flawless culminating in
the revelation of zoro's conqueror haki
but this isn't the highlight of the
fight not by far heard by King's taunts
about aspiring to be a king after
unveiling his haki Zoro cleverly dubs
his new technique king of hell with it
he not only neutralizes his opponent's
scorching magma likee flame attack but
also inflicts a severe wound on the
lunarian sing one of his wings brawling
through the length and breath of wano
Zoro has consistently delivered
remarkable victories to the extent that
he became the only individual after Odin
to deeply wound kaido with his triumph
over King Zorro keeps his promise to
Luffy to never lose a fight furthermore
he contributes to substantial cating
Luffy's dream of one day becoming the
pirate king the question now arises can
any future battle surpass the Brilliance
of this encounter well that's something
only time will
[Applause]
[Music]
tell
throughout one piece there have been
numerous remarkable character
introductions yet none quite compared to
our Runners up today the ominous nature
of the grand line is vividly portrayed
as yonko kaido hailed as the strongest
creature across land sea and air makes
his highly anticipated
[Music]
entrance well since this intro
introductory scene apart from the rest
is the gripping way he plummets from a
sky island and lands on the kids's
Pirates base seemingly attempting
suicide and coming out of it unscathed
the governor general of the animal
kingdom Pirates isn't your average
pirate he has earned reputation for
being virtually indestructible having
survived hanging torture and even the
guillotine with such a formidable
Persona the Dragon Emperor is akin to
God until Luffy eventually tobbles him
however this doesn't diminish the
uniqueness of his character marked by
excessive drinking and an insatiable
desire for a good opponent understanding
the weariness of a Powerhouse like kaido
living in a world lacking in worthy
adversaries adds depth to his character
despite meeting his end in a spectacular
clash with Luffy he does so honorably
and entertainingly ending with his
iconic move the Drunken Dragon
bagua
Hy at long last it's time to reveal the
biggest Flex to date and it's none other
than redhead shank's arrival during the
Paramount War where he effortlessly
concludes the conflict not just through
his imposing presence but also with the
subtle suggestion of a potential
confrontation with the
Marines astonishingly not only does
fleet Admiral sangoku quickly comply
with shank's request but the Marines the
Blackbeard Pirates and whitebeard's crew
too all back off without a murmur with a
mere request from the yonko sangoku even
agrees to entrust Shanks with the
responsibility of laying Whitebeard and
Ace to rest the Intrigue deepens later
as Shanks unexpectedly appears at the Ry
and is allowed to meet with the Arrogant
five Elders of the world government as
someone who has stayed strictly in the
background of Luffy's Journey shank's
mysterious appearance in wano and his
declaration to go after the one piece
further thrust this elusive character
into the foreground speculating anymore
about his future role is a delicate
matter so we'll refrain from that right
now nonetheless Shanks undeniably steals
the spotlight with every appearance
particularly with his impactful
intervention in
[Music]
marineford and that concludes the top 20
one piece flexes of all time brought to
you by vinu we can be sure the one piece
still has plenty of surprises in store
for us do share your thoughts in the
comments section below and don't forget
to hit the like button and subscribe for
additional anime content until next time
ciao